[Musique]
je suis très heureux de vous présenter
Catherine et Gilles Blanchard vous êtes
famille d'accueil pour une association
qui s'appelle mécénat et chirurgie
cardiaque qui accueille voilà des
enfants qui viennent souvent d'Afrique
et qui ont des malformations cardiaques
et qui doivent être opérés en France
donc il faut des familles d'accueil pour
les accueillir
vous avez accueilli beaucoup d'enfants
pour cette association et ça fait assez
longtemps que vous le faites d'ailleurs
comment tout ça a commencé
alors ça a commencé parce qu'on
connaissait on avait connaissance de
l'existence de mes Sénat
chirurgicardiaque puisque on connaissait
bien son cofondateur Patrice roannette
partant de là on avait du temps
disponible notamment ma femme qui était
qui avait pris sa retraite et on ayant
ce temps disponible on dit mais il
faudrait l'utiliser à quelque chose
d'utile qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire du
style et automatiquement est arrivé
l'idée de faire famille d'accueil pour
le mécénat parce que la cause des
enfants
avec des soucis de santé et de leur
redonner un avenir un peu un peu plus
convenable face à nous ça nous plaisait
bien et et
c'est ce qu'on a fait on a on s'est
rapproché du mécénat pour accueillir
pour présenter notre candidature à faire
famille d'accueil et ça commence c'était
quoi 2013 le premier
ou petite fille Aïcha
elle avait trois ans à peu près et en
fait ses enfants arrivent pour un mois
deux mois voire plus suivant les
pathologies
généralement de naissance
que on peut pas les opérer dans leur
période d'origine donc il faut il faut
les amener en France c'est le but de
Messenger cardiaque c'est un enfance de
les faire opérer par des très beaux
médecins donc de leur sauver la vie
évidemment mais tout ça est long
quand vous les accueillez c'est juste un
peu avant l'opération comment ça se
passe
je vous dirai un enfant arrive ce matin
à l'aéroport nous avons cherché le
lendemain on est reçu par Francine le
cas au mécénat qui fait le petit bilan
qui veut voir l'enfant ensuite
nous prenons rendez-vous avec un
généraliste généraliste pour que le qui
confirme qu'il n'y ait pas de rhume de
problèmes respiratoires de rayons voilà
dentiste éventuellement mais c'est un
drame bon c'est compliqué et puis à
partir de là on a des rendez-vous à
l'hôpital avant l'opération on est bilan
d'accord oui il y a des binocons
l'opération donc c'est ça vous
l'accueillez dès son arrivée en France
à l'aéroport souvent à 6h du matin
et donc ça c'est pas un grand moment
c'est un arrachement parce que en fait
ils ont arraché leur famille alors nous
on a un tout petit en général
donc pour eux c'est une souffrance parce
que on les sort de leur milieu
évidemment un peu différent de ce qui
vit habituellement et on n'est pas dans
les bras c'est des étranges on est des
étrangers
la période de où on fait connaissance
avec vous faut être comment il faut être
là il faut être très très doux très très
patient patient il faut leur montrer
qu'on est là pour leur bien donc
évidemment pas de mouvement d'humeur etc
et leur faire sentir que on est là pour
pour du bien-être mais il y a trois
quatre jours qui sont un peu compliqués
les trois quatre mesures sont compliqués
parce que eux évidemment ils sont
complètement déracinés
le système d'alimentation c'est tout
bête mais il consomme pas du tout la
même les mêmes ingrédients que nous donc
il faut aussi s'adapter alors il y a une
phase qui est compliqué mais qui passe
assez vite et ils sont évidemment enfin
des tas de souffrance mais enfin ils
sont pas encore opérés donc ils ont ils
sont il faut attention ils sont fatigués
généralement ils sont très fatigués
mais le grand changement c'est après
l'adoration
alors un petit peu plus un petit peu
plus hein
le temps des examens des autres c'est
une petite semaine après donc il y a
l'opérations
[Musique]
à l'hôpital oui oui c'est assez rapide
dans l'ensemble suivant l'intervention
c'est ces trois trois jours quatre jours
elle est au quotidien
il faut aller les voir tous les jours et
par rapport à notre lieu de d'habitation
nous on dépend de l'hôpital de Marie
Lannelongue au Plessis-Robinson donc
tous les examens sont faits d'abord
l'opération également donc tous les
jours
donc l'opération a lieu bon
on espère qu'elle se passe bien ce qui
arrive dans la majorité des cas et là
donc il reviennent chez vous
alors ils reviennent
ils reviennent tout va bien et si
l'intervention était minime sinon il y a
une maison de convalescence
mais en général c'est une grosse en
moyenne on va dire une grosse semelle
là vous allez voir tous les jours
il commence à s'habituer à vous oui
pas juste tu es un cas maghjid qui m'en
voulait
ah oui je rappelle Mathilde parce que en
fait l'espace tout ça est sur un espace
court donc le moment où il s'habitue à
nous c'est grosso modo une semaine 10
jours et au bout d'une semaine du mois
après l'opération de nouveau il y a une
coupure donc là il nous en vole
elle est occupée
pendant quelques jours ça a été
plus conscient de ce qui se passait les
petites 2 ans et demi 3 ans
alors donc là après la convalescence le
retour dans la maison c'est vous hein
peut aussi vous constater les
l'amélioration de la santé je suppose
très peu quand ils arrivent ils sont
affaiblis déjà
le grand plaisir des familles d'accueil
c'est quand ils commencent à manger à
avoir faim et après l'opération une
semaine après l'opération il mange et ça
moi qui suis maman c'est un petit
bonheurs
plus en forme donc tout de suite ils
peuvent courir ils peuvent jouer au
ballon et puis on les balade
alors c'est c'est tu dis ça parce que
peut-être qu'il y a des gens qui
regardent qui s'interrogent faut savoir
qui serait tenté de dire que la famille
d'accueil alors c'est quand même du
boulot quoi enfin c'est du boulot c'est
il faut s'occuper il faut avoir le temps
de s'occuper d'eux c'est ça il faut être
libre vaut mieux être disponible
complètement disponible
en tout cas faut faire en sorte de
l'être on peut pas faire ça en
pointillés tout à l'heure d'une amie à
vous qui a été famille d'accueil qui a
arrêté de travailler le taux
qui a pris un congé pour faire pour
faire famille d'accueil parce que vous
voulez vraiment réaliser cette envie
c'est une envie forte et alors je sais
plus elle avait pris un congé de 3-4
mois parce que pour
réaliser son envie
d'enfants et mais c'est vrai que comme
dit Catherine après après l'opération là
c'est vrai c'est vraiment formidable et
à peu près alors
comme pour nos enfants petits le matin
alors il y a quelques fois des nuits
compliquées alors notamment on a eu un
petit garçon de 6 ans il avait pas
l'habitude de dormir dans un lit un vrai
lit et donc il avait sa chambre à part
avec un lit assez bas pour pas et la
nuit je le retrouvais au pied de notre
lit partir sur le parquet je le prenais
je la réveillais j'en mettais dans son
lit
être par terre parce qu'il voulait être
plus près de vous aussi et par terre
parce que le lit c'est pour lui il
connaissait pas
violent et perturbant c'est que on se
rend pas trop
et il était il venait des Comores une
petite île des Comores il vivait avec sa
grand-mère parce que les parents étaient
partis je crois qu'ils étaient partis à
Mayotte pour essayer de glaner un petit
travail et de ramener quelque chose ils
vivent avec sa grand-mère et coucher par
terre on peut comprendre que d'arriver
d'un seul coup dans un milieu qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce truc
par terre
on a des petites inquiétudes comme ça
et on est toujours derrière on est
toujours derrière en fait ce qui nous a
aussi beaucoup surpris c'est qu'on
devient très vite parent de nouveau
c'est très frappé
on les connaissait pas deux mois avant
et vous prenez ces petits bouts de choux
là et d'un seul coup on redevient par an
et on a les mêmes
angoisses que si c'était génétiquement
qui se crée assez rapidement avec et de
leur part aussi de leur part pas tout de
suite
et certains ne sont pas habitués aux
embrassades mais c'est vrai au début
même Aïcha
après l'opération des bonnes joues ils
sont ils sont
il y a un mouvement de recul
très vite
c'est pas mal quoi
la première fois ils prennent une douche
ou un bain certains ne connaissaient pas
évidemment enfin généralement enfin dans
les cas les plus courants il retrouve de
plus en plus
vous le voyez il commence à s'amuser à
courir
comme des enfants
absolument et ça ça doit être une grande
joie parce que là ces missions
accomplies
récupérer
la capacité d'adaptation si nous on est
aussi on est aussi surpris que nous on
devient parents mais
pour eux on devient des parents de
substitutions
alors on faisait pas appeler papa
donc
la ça dure combien de temps de séjour là
ça dépend je pense des des cas mais
bon on a eu un peu plus court le moins
un mois et demi
un mois et alors on va dire en moyenne
de moi après il peut y avoir des
complications sur certains cas
et ça peut et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
quand même se réserver un temps un peu
long on va dire bah c'est de moi c'est
de moi
voilà on sait pas qu'on commence on sait
pas on sait à peu près mais pas bon
c'est pas une semaine près
s'il y a un petit souci dans notre
famille pour un temps plus long et des
familles relais
dans la famille un dessert il y a des
familles relais pour ça comme nous on
l'a été une fois pour des paniers
on arrive au terme de du séjour
mais il y a un attachement qui s'est
créé et quand il repartent on les ramène
à l'aéroport
c'est il repartent avec leurs cadeaux
ils font comme ça
on reprend notre voiture on se parle
plus et on perd
c'est étonnant surtout les premiers
enfants après
disant allez c'est bon
six fois et puis on va parler de quelque
chose qui va se produire bientôt mais
vous diriez quoi que ça bonheur des
grands bonheurs de votre vie quoi
humainement c'est une très belle
aventure
des petits livres alors ça c'est vous
qui les faites Catherine avec
alors c'est des photos quoi c'est des
photos des séjours alors là c'est ce que
vous avez apporté mais vous leur donnez
absolument c'est repartent avec un
exemplaire de l'album calendrier
des petites livres c'est mignon comme
tout quoi
voilà et alors voilà je voulais parler
de celui-là en particulier
parce que alors il avait trois ans là
c'est celui-là c'est Dalida excusez-moi
alors là il avait 3 ans quand il est
venu chez vous
et
donc ce qui va se passer c'est qu'il va
revenir chez vous absolument quelques
mois absolument on a été sollicité par
le mécénat qui nous a avertis que Dylan
devait revenir en France pour se faire
réopérer ça c'est normal parce que quand
on grandit voilà il faut changer les
valves
exactement et donc ils nous ont demandé
si on était prêt à le reprendre pour
on a même pas réfléchi on a dit oui
parce que après évidemment
il y a ce moment évidemment extrêmement
fort qui vous lit à ses enfants et puis
après
et ce qui est bien normal il reprenne
leur vie et et donc
vos relations vous avez des relations
parfois avec la famille avec et vos
relations avec eux ça se passe un peu ce
qui est il faut les laisser vivre
ça c'est normal c'est tout mais oui et
là il va se souvenir et qu'il avait été
chez vous alors c'est pas sûr ça non
parce qu'il avait 2 ans et demi
il aura pouvoir n'est pas je pense
exactement et peut-être que ça avait
essayé quelque chose parce que pour lui
aussi c'est quelque chose de de violence
qui m'est arrivé donc peut-être que ça
peut éveiller quelque chose mais au
moins on pourra lui dire bah on te
connaît déjà on te connaît déjà c'est
génial ça c'est génial je sais pas si
c'était arrivé à d'autres failles mais
bon
ce qui vient de se passer mais là c'est
formidable parce qu'il y a 10 ans alors
là on à l'emmener à Paris on va lui
faire en va l'emmener au château de
Versailles et on va il va d'autres
activités évidemment
vous disiez le plus âgé que vous avez vu
c'était 6 ans je crois donc oui il y a
d'autres activités
et vous êtes un peu impatients donc
oui vous êtes heureux
ça va nous faire une petite piqûre de
rappel si vous avez bien un conseil
comme ça à donner des gens qui qui se
disent bah voilà au sein d'entrer mais
on hésite un peu
quel est le conceptique enfin ce qu'il
faut savoir quoi avant de s'engager
c'est que c'est du temps
il faut pas que ce soit faut pas que ça
fasse jolie dans un dîner en ville
c'est pas le projet il faut vraiment
aimer les enfants être conscient de de
la mission aller au bout de la mission
si tu penses à
est disponible et
je tiens quand même le souligner c'est
un petit investissement pour chaque
famille d'accueil
parce que j'étais sollicitée une fois
dans un magasin par une petite famille
qui m'a demandé ce que je faisais et si
ça vient le coup oui c'est un coup c'est
un coup donc ils arrivent où les
habiller parce que bien souvent ils ont
un petit sac à dos ils sont ils ont rien
dedans
l'alimentation bon encore ça va mais il
y a le carburant tous les jours il y a
la voiture donc les familles il faut
qu'elle le sache il faut le savoir il y
a un petit coup il y a un petit budget à
mettre pour ça est-ce que vous avez fait
je crois que c'est pour je crois que
c'est pour lui aussi c'est autre chose
ça c'est pas obligatoire c'est-à-dire
que vous
aidez à financer ces études c'est ça on
le parait c'est du parrainage et en fait
on fait un petit versement mensuel
d'accord pour le soutenir dans sa
scolarité et il vous le rend bien parce
que les premiers
tout le monde en a des retours
fantastiques et alors les fonds ne vont
pas directement à la famille c'est
important de savoir mais c'est là qui
reverse ça mes Sénat et le mécénat est
en charge de renvoyer les fonds et de
s'assurer que ça va bien pour la
scolarité donc on a l'assurance que
c'est pas la provocation
bravo et alors vous êtes vous avez une
maison
c'est mieux une maison c'est mieux une
merci merci à vous
[Musique]